nazis and witches in the forest a royal
hunt for a mermaid ridiculous use of
green screen and oscar nominees sinking
to new lows the worst movies of 2022
have to be seen to be believed except
that you might scratch your eyes out if
you do see them so watch this video
instead here's an erotic thriller in the
vein of fatal attraction and basic
instinct but with none of the verve
shattered stars cameron monahan is chris
a recently divorced tech mogul who falls
for a stranger named skye in a grocery
store skye is just too perfect that's
obvious right away but chris can't see
it you could argue that he's blinded by
her charms but the sad truth is that the
film is just poorly written when chris
gets targeted in a seemingly random
attack and ends up with a broken leg
skye becomes his live-in nurse by the
time she is revealed as an unhinged home
invader who's only interested in chris
for his money were already bored the sex
scenes are nowhere near as steamy as
advertised with little to no spark
shared between the co-stars that's
largely on chris being so profoundly
bland that we're basically rooting for
sky once the violence starts
a world war ii flick with witches and an
eye patch wearing mickey rourke warhand
shows some promise before quickly
descending into shellock when an
american cargo plane goes down in
germany's black forest works major
johnson pulls together a team of his
best men and sends them to retrieve the
precious cargo when they get close to
the crash site they discover the bodies
of several dead nazis bearing mysterious
symbols and when their compasses
suddenly fail they start to suspect
something supernatural spoiler alert
there's a coven of witches in the forest
it's an interesting setup but it doesn't
work when all the characters are just
macho stereotypes warhunt at least looks
pretty slick but it's also completely
devoid of fresh ideas as awful
one-liners begin to pile up any goodwill
that was built up in the opening stages
rapidly disappears stop that crap right
now helmed by long-time x-men writer
producer director simon kinberg the 355
is the sort of film that really should
have been a lot better this globe
trotting spy flick is forward thinking
and features some top tier talent but
none of them can elevate this generic
thriller if you must know the plot it
features jessica chastain as mason brown
a no-nonsense cia agent who has to team
up with other female spies from around
the globe to prevent a decryption drive
capable of hacking any system on earth
from falling into the wrong hands the
critics weren't especially kind and we
don't blame them despite their
considerable talents the cast of lupita
nyong'o penelope cruz diane kruger and
fan bing couldn't do much with the
clunky dialogue or the played out
cliches the 355 is a waste of talent and
of everyone's time
he rose to fame as a fake prince in
2019's aladdin but mina masood plays a
real prince in 2022's the royal
treatment unfortunately it's a formulaic
and forgettable netflix rom-com prince
thomas lives in a castle and has his
every need attended to but he's just a
normal guy underneath it all he meets a
hairdresser named izzy after his
assistant accidentally calls her salon
and hires her for a one-off haircut of
course it becomes more than a one-off
izzy leaves the prince's hair
half-finished after witnessing a member
of the royal staff being treated poorly
and he's forced to seek her out so that
she can finish it sounds romantic but
there's no spark here and all the comedy
half of the rom-com is missing as well
the royal treatment is an undeniably
humorless and tedious affair from start
to finish even if you're obsessed with
royal romances there are several better
options on netflix like a christmas
prince the royal wedding which is far
from a classic but it's citizen kane
compared to this glorified lifetime
movie
a historical fantasy that spent years in
production health the king's daughter
stars pierce brosnan as king louis xiv
of france who sends his men to search
for a mythical mermaid louis wants to
live forever and he believes the mermaid
can make that happen alas his plan gets
derailed when his illegitimate daughter
learns of the mermaid's existence this
isn't one of those films that's so bad
it's good it's just straight up bad and
we mean bad the king's daughter is an
adaptation of the novel the moon and the
sun which won the nebula award in 1997.
it's a fantastic read but the movie does
it a huge disservice paramount removed
the film from its release schedule just
weeks before it was due to hit cinemas
in 2015 with no explanation years passed
before it saw the light of day and when
that eventually happened it was easy to
see why it was hidden away for so long
as the whole thing just meanders before
flopping to an unsatisfying finish
in the style of the happy madison
produced netflix films before it the
kevin james lead home team falls far
short of funny this gross out sports
comedy is loosely based on the real life
story of football coach sean payton who
became the new offensive coordinator of
his son's sixth grade team during his
one year suspension from the nfl it's a
fascinating story but home team isn't
particularly interested in the
nitty-gritty this is a pg comedy
starring a bunch of kids after all that
would be forgivable if it were funny but
the script lacks any true laugh out loud
moments as it also fails to capitalize
on the potential of peyton's unlikely
saga james plays peyton as a permanently
scowling man's man who knows next to
nothing about his son and that shouldn't
come as much of a surprise to those who
have seen their fair share of adam
sandler produced films as amy nicholson
of the new york times put it the facts
have been rejiggered to fit the
sandman's formula our hero is a seething
screw-up and everyone else is even worse
we're not mad at home team we're just
disappointed in the right hands it could
have been a touchdown but instead it's a
lazy comedy that just isn't worth your
time we get it
you fall down you're heavy
[ __ ] hilarious perhaps the world just
isn't ready to laugh at the collective
trauma that was the covet 19 pandemic
the bubble marks a major misfire for its
director master of comedy judd apatow
the story is about the chaotic
production of cliff beasts 6 battle for
everest memories of a requiem a crummy
blockbuster franchise movie shooting
during covet 19 lockdowns this requires
the cast of spoiled stars to stay in
their rooms act against green screens
and endure health protocols all of which
they snottily bristle against simply put
the bubble is a certifiable dud perhaps
its biggest sin is that despite one of
the most formidable casts of comedically
skilled actors ever assembled it doesn't
provide nearly enough laughs as katie
rife of polygon mercilessly described it
the bubble is composed mainly of long
excruciating sequences where everyone is
trying very hard and producing zero
laughs like people trying to start a
fire by rubbing two wet sticks together
thanks to an agreement put in place
before disney's marvel cinematic
universe took off sony controls the film
rights to several lesser-known
characters from the spider-man canon
this has resulted in the two somewhat
well-received venom flicks but then in
2022 we were subjected to morbius it
stars human punchline jared leto as
living vampire michael morbius a
scientist who cures himself of a blood
disorder with an experimental treatment
of his own design hello
i'm a morbius
i'm a very scary vampire oh i'mma gonna
suck you blood
michael also accidentally makes himself
a very special vampire as he feasts on
the blood of humans and also has
superpowers this fuels his epic battle
for the ages against milo his surrogate
brother who has the same blood disease
and contracts the same powers but
becomes the evil counterpart to
michael's good vampire currently morbius
is the worst reviewed film yet in sony's
spiderman adjacent cinematic universe
and we have to agree with that
assessment you'll be begging to have all
the blood drained out of your arteries
while watching
boone is like a charles bronson 70s
vigilante movie but without the cultural
context bewildering urban setting or
extreme violence that for better or for
worse made those flicks compelling and
unique it's also basically a late career
liam neeson style revenge flick but
without neeson's charisma or star power
instead boone is about a hired gun named
nick boone played by tv cop show veteran
neil mcdonough who's seeking redemption
after a long and toxic career is the
muscle and hired killer for a criminal
organization boone moves to a remote
town in the pacific northwest and takes
up with a poor widow and her young son
but he realizes that his new life is
much like his old one when a crime lord
terrorizes his new family thereby
forcing him to violently make things
right with the world not too many
critics even bothered to review boone
but those who did basically hated it as
brian orndorff of bluray.com scoffed
when the budget is this low and the star
power this minimal it's best to go crazy
with action which this picture tries to
avoid until the final act
the makers of measure of revenge seem to
be motivated by a desire to craft a film
as seedy as possible but without the
quirky characters or daring plot
necessary to justify a descent into the
grimiest parts of human existence but
ultimately they just made it by the
numbers revenge fantasy oscar winner
melissa leo plays lillian cooper a
legendary broadway actress about to
retire whose son is found dead
supposedly from an accidental drug
overdose but lillian has her doubts so
she becomes a one-woman mystery-solving
criminal punishing army that army
doubles in size when she forms a strange
partnership with bella thorne as taz her
son's dealer who may have all the
answers perhaps the only reason to watch
measure of revenge is to try to figure
out how someone like leo ended up in it
as michael nordin a variety posited
viewers are likely to spend more time
wondering how she came to be involved
with such a shoestring production than
sympathizing with her character
i'm not blaming anyone redeeming love
demonstrates that it's difficult to make
a morally uplifting movie about a time
and place intrinsically associated with
debauchery without causing serious tonal
whiplash set in a california gold rush
boom town in 1850 the film focuses on
the on the nose named angel a young
woman sold to bad men when she was a
child who grows up to be a sex worker
against her will she internalizes the
abuse and is riddled with self-hatred
until the morally upstanding michael
appears and shows angel that a little
bit of love and attention can apparently
heal any and all deep psychological
wounds in other words redeeming love is
literally and quite awkwardly a movie
about redeeming love as you can imagine
critics were not especially kind towards
redeeming love which they found more
manipulative than profound as jade
wudowski of decider declared redeeming
love fails as both a compelling romance
and an effective drama failing to do its
dazzling leading lady or anyone else
justice whatsoever
in 2022 horror master jason blum and
oscar winner akiva goldsmith supervised
a remake of a mediocre adaptation of a
lesser effort from stephen king you
might remember goldsmith from his work
on the dark tower another bomb based on
a king novel like the 1984 version the
2022 fire starter tells the story of
parents andy and vicky dealing with
their young daughter charlie who has the
ability to start fires with her mind
thanks to some evil government
experimentation they've successfully
spent their lives on the lam from the
agents who wish to capture charlie and
weaponize her powers the young girl has
been able to keep her ability in check
for most of her life but not so much
anymore critics across the board pretty
much agreed that the new fire starter
was not just unnecessary but also
unequivocally terrible as nick schager
of the daily beast put it the only mood
conjured by this dud is one of extreme
torpor
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]